welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
vost and marvel's what if season finale
showed the watcher assembling the
guardians of the multiverse to fight
ultron round after round until that
genius final move of trapping him in a
snow globe you foresaw every moment from
the failed infinity crusher to
killmonger's betrayal and my
your sacrifice ah yes another schemer
supreme the watcher joins dr strange act
of the harkness and kang and the it was
this [ __ ] all along
club the kind of masterminds you can
weave together random uh-o's into a
flawless victory but what exactly was
the watcher's plan in all of its steps
how far back had he been planning it and
since this finale was titled what if the
watcher broke his oath what does that
plan tell us about what consequences the
watcher will face in marvel's future
after getting caught with his pants down
on episode 7 and losing to ultron in
episode 8 the watcher explained in the
finale i scoured eternity for one true
hero then i saw the bigger picture this
mission requires a team the perfect
combination of skills and experience
that alone will triumph that initial one
true hero was probably doctor strange he
was one who empowered each guardian with
magical armor and he ultimately encased
this mess in a pocket dimension but the
watcher knew that strange could not do
this alone because even a powerful nexus
being like himself wasn't enough to beat
ultron so that led to this lineup with
the perfect combination of skills and
experience a pretty vague prerequisite
that really means the personality traits
and life experiences of these heroes
each contributed to the recipe so
joining strange the watcher adds captain
carter star-lord t'challa thanos killing
gamora black panther killmonger and
party thor now the watcher also needed
black widow from ultron's home reality
but he delayed adding her to the team at
first i'll explain why in a bit but
let's start with party thor who might be
the most immature and inexperienced thor
in the multiverse so why choose him well
notice the moment right before the
watcher deploys them slow down a little
bit there's a few people in the room
that don't understand
not me i get it but for them maybe
repeat it
you're ready yeah see the watcher fully
expected thor to stupidly alert ultra
onto their presence to make ultron think
he was on the offensive when actually he
was on the defensive had he done nothing
he could have still been king of the
multiverse and he brought in thor is
just kind of a dum-dum to smash
everything to make ultron think that
he's dealing with some outmatched dopes
in order to further frustrate ultron
when he couldn't kill those dopes who
were unworthy of his time and when the
watcher grabbed thor by surprise thor
also contributes the key component of a
severed ultron sentry head next captain
carter is unique among cap variants in
the multiverse and that not only is she
a strong leader accustomed to being out
of her temporal element her experience
traveling through portals and fighting
squid monsters proves her an apt
candidate for a multiversal conflict in
the heat of battle she orders give him
all you've got don't give him a chance
to think knowing that this team won't
beat ultron outright but can distract
him long enough to extract the stones
which also explains why star-lord
t'challa is so crucial to this team
because he's a heist expert with sticky
fingers scoff all you want but it was
the move tony stark needed to snatch his
stones from thanos and end game so
t'challa snatches the soul stone early
on making ultron get super protective of
his preciouses and have a reason to
chase the team back to that home reality
next drax's favorite question
why is gamora well gamora slayed the
last big bad thanos and brings the
infinity crusher to the table now by the
way the watcher decidedly did not want
tony stark not used why well because
stark would probably have tried to
outsmart his own creation which
definitely would not have worked and
spelled doom for the rest of the team
now doctor strange said the watcher
foresaw the infinity crusher's failure
so why include that in the plan well i
think the watcher needed to make ultron
think that the guardians team thought it
was their final goal because notice how
ultron afterwards so smugly lectures
every universe is different each one
just a fraction you meet
the crusher was designed to destroy the
stones on my world not his yeah this
misdirect was crucial and it tells us
why the watcher sat out of most of this
fight because ultron had no way of
knowing the watcher assembled this team
if he did know the watcher was minded he
wouldn't bother lecturing them about how
one universe is a fraction different
than the others no one knows that better
than watcher ultron clearly now thinks
he's just fighting a bunch of random
rookies who tripped into the multiverse
not a team perfectly recruited and
coached by the multiverse's bill
belichick hey by the way recently new
rockstars decided to do something to
give back to try to improve the world
beyond producing theory videos and
easter egg videos and we did some
homework and found a really great
non-profit based in gainesville florida
that's where a bunch of us here at new
rock stars including myself philip zack
brandon all met and went to school we
found an amazing team at community
spring it's a 501 c 3 non-profit
organization dedicated to dismantling
structural poverty and spurring economic
mobility at a grassroots level they
focus on providing income and building
power income to meet people's needs and
power to reshape the systems that keep
them down community spring is one of the
few organizations in the southeastern
united states that addresses poverty at
the root while centering the people most
impacted by it their flagship program is
a fellowship that hires the people that
have been impacted by poverty while they
work to address the issues contributing
to poverty in their communities and
they've done really great work with
covet 19 relief and people returning
from incarceration we've talked a lot
with the folks at community spring and
we really believe in their work we're
donating money to help them do more to
fight structural poverty in gainesville
and we would love you to join us so
click the link in the video's
description to learn more about their
work and if you can donate and so from
that turning point of the infinity
crusher failing ultron now focuses on
doctor strange recognizing him as the
key mvp who sources the protection
spells for the rest and he's not wrong
but by aiming most of his attention on
doctor strange ultron gives himself
blind spots and that is where natasha
comes in and why the watcher delayed her
arrival see the watcher was
eavesdropping in episode 8 when natasha
said hard copies are harder to steal
easier to destroy but code
code is slippery and it never dies and
his head turned to natasha right as she
said that i'm sorry to play the watcher
here but there that's the moment though
watcher's plan truly began he knew that
zola's ai virus would be needed to
corrupt ultron's ai but he couldn't just
hand over an infinity android body from
one evil code to another evil code also
if he brought in natasha too early
ultron could have gotten wise to that
ace in the hole natasha needed to
release that zola arrow at the last
second precisely as ultron was at his
blindest overconfident that he finally
had the guardians cornered and now that
zola overthrows ultron we must enter the
true end game and why it was crucial for
killmonger to participate on this team
because at this point they really have
just swapped out one evil code for
another right and code is slippery it
never dies so the watcher needed one
team member so cravenly power hungry
that he's forever unable to resist his
grasp for a more powerful weapon and so
enter killmonger a warrior the watcher
fully expects to betray the rest even
from the beginning when he first
recruited him killmonger tony stark's
former protege
and killer yeah his eyes narrowed when
he called him killer he knows what he's
dealing with and he motivates killmonger
with this ultron century head made of
vibranium like his own suit ahead with a
lingering hive mind linked to ultron's
corpse and that head becomes
killmonger's fixation his ring of power
an itch that can never fully be
scratched but a scab he keeps picking at
nonetheless killmonger is really the
perfect counterbalance to the ambitious
persistent code of zola in his newly
acquired ultron shell neither of them
can let these stones go forever
neutralizing the stones in this tug of
war and strange finally realizes this we
were never meant to win
we were here to separate the stones from
the body and so only now does the
watcher rise from the bench and help
strange trap this threat in a pocket
reality within the pocket reality
strange's uncontrollable self is
contained within double layer protection
that way and now giving strange an
eternal purpose of guardianship now the
problem is this is a lot of meddling for
a being who seems to have a
non-intervention policy despite how
inconsistently he applies it so as the
episode title asks what does happen when
the watcher breaks his oath i think
that's gonna be the big question for
season two and this episode gave us a
bit of an answer if you're looking
closely you can't tell me there's not
another big bad lurking in the shadows
monster under the bed now tony and
gamora came from an episode that was
delayed from season one and pushed to
season two and i now think this episode
is being reworked to fit into season two
and the new major threat of next season
and as tony talks about what's on the
horizon the face of the watcher looms
into view the watcher's oath was with a
council of watchers who could enact the
cruel penance of torturing uatu to stare
at only the most awful heartbreaking
tragedies unfold before his helpless
unblinking eyes they could also doom him
to mortality as a kind of guru that
marvel heroes seek for wisdom but with
even less power i just think our watcher
is now on a journey toward hands-on
benevolent cooperation which might put
him at odds both with his own watchers
and with their meddling rivals the
celestials you can support new rockstars
by checking out our merch options at
nerocstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at e8 boss follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you